ein riesenpenis geht kondome kaufen
[Applaus]
willkommen zu einem neuen video gemacht
heute wieder zum abschluss der woche um
auch diesen sonntag im schönen deckel
drauf zu machen einen ausflug in die
welt der verbotenen kommentar horde
wilder vollgeschlagen ist 50 milliarden
stunden vorm pc also nur warum mir ewig
keine idee kein video eingefallen jetzt
aber dachte ich mir wir können noch mal
wieder und mit netten helfern und
gebrachten menschen auf youtube
beschäftigen arbeit machen wir erstmal
ein christ und zwar das kürzel jemand
helfen kann man ein kleiner go ist das
wurde mir den kommentaren vorgeschlagen
damit die frage bis zum keller goya nein
vielleicht
der online bist du ein kleiner gag sein
büro natürlich nicht und tut als sind
alle schwer war schon der frage bist du
ein kleiner grob er muss sich
selbstverständlich in übereinstimmung zu
meinen bisherigen antworten mit
vielleicht antworten auswertung du bist
ein kenner grob alles gehörte da haben
wir das auch in erfahrung gebracht dann
können wir alle sagen er mir einen
kommentar von peri haben sich leichter
an der schreibt unseres youtuber stark
effekt erraten die lucchini vida loca an
war er verloren hat
alles klar liberia und es gibt kreativ
weiter liebe leute der nächsten schreibt
könnt ihr mein video anklicken ich
möchte aufrufe wäre sehr nett auch
nötiger ok aller welt nicht ihren
kommentar
was ist eure meinung zwischen kommentare
stimmte damit überein würdet ihr sagen
berichtet so oder so kontrollieren
werden schreibt die kommentare
ja und da haben wir das hier wie kam
dieser text stande instagram instagram
logo entwickler erscheinungsjahr
variiert je nach gerät er den anderen
betriebssystemen kann mir irgendwas euch
erklären wie die der text zustande kam
hilfe bietet geht richtig ab aber es
geht nie gegen münchen verantwortet der
unterschied zwischen apparat und einer
schweins mutter
was würdet ihr sagen bassist unterschied
zwischen upgrade und einer schweins
mutter ich meinen die frage abstimmen
selbst gestellt oder die antwort ist
selbstverständlich mit eines dummen
fabriziert und frisst nur scheiße und
das andere ist eine schweizer mutter ich
gemein sagt doch nicht so was heute
sollte ja muss die unterwelt begeben
okay wer muss das reich der verbotenen
und tendierten kommentare gegeben und es
trifft eine grausamkeit nach der anderen
ein sprachliches umgetrieben entspannt
monster nach dem anderen und das nächste
was uns erscheint ist ein riesenpenis
geht kondome kaufen lacht miley berlins
weil ich so meine freunde macht auch was
zur hölle es ist einfach wirklich ein
riesenpenis der kondome einkaufen geht
was ist mit dem tonlos alter das ist so
was ja wunderbar schön dass wir oben
rechts auf den bio vorschlag haben
bietet der perfekte bild aus fiel dann
die aluminium lifestyle will unbedingt
wissen was für dich der perfekte penis
ist der kommentar ist auch irgendwas auf
geblockt und zwar out of the day
lederjacke stört verfolger tätig war
wird immer unterstellt ich würde in box
ort da sitzen das stimmt mich bestimmt
wirklich nicht ich habe eigentlich immer
eine hose an wenn ich aufnehme denn ich
höre ich nur einem t shirts sitzen würde
nicht bemerken aber ich bin irgendwie
mega via das ist ungefähr so als geht
man auch einen spielplatz suchen sicher
aus nein ich wünsche euch nächster
kommentar von ilike pizza auch der block
versöhnen grund chatter bekommt das halt
nicht angeblich gesagt haben wenn ihr es
auch mit dann gönnt euch heroin können
diese augen lügen leute können diese
augen euch auf der täter drohen ihren
wenn euch diese fällt nein das kann doch
gar nicht sein also das wird noch
unterstellung ich glaube es hat auch
keiner von euch gesehen liebevoller mich
wahrscheinlich gewundert warum so wenige
beleidigenden kommentaren sind das liegt
daran dass mein letztes video gegen dann
macht er unter apache mit dem länger her
ist aber wer mit gefreut und fitness die
auf die ganzen dinge da haben wir zum
beispiel den youtube-nutzern namen dark
knight feier hat übersetzte viel heißen
dunkle ritter feuer und natürlich auch
name ist er darauf dass die person sehr
alten bereitet in der kommentare geben
wird auch wenn sie schreibt was hast du
gegen luca so kleiner missgeburt mach
dich selber noch mal wieder machen meine
eltern mich gemacht bescheid macht ich
selber noch mal ich glaub du bekommst du
[ __ ]
manche menschen manche menschen sind
einfach nicht dem sauerstoff werten wie
eine laterne von dennis hd der weiter an
loki hörten wir zu gott zu sagen hat
leute hört auf über der werbung zu
sprechen statt sp sein kanal alles
klappt kann die botschaft an bei euch
habt ihr das alles verstanden
wir dürfen nicht über der werbung
sprechen okay wenn ihr gesicht geschaut
mit euren freund die werbung spielt
müsste die schnauze halten denn jetzt
hat die sagt das fernsehen schaut und es
läuft werbung im fernsehen müsst ihr die
schnauze halten in dem moment das ist so
dennis hd hat es so gesagt der kanadier
main kanal deswegen müssen alle neu die
weltweit immer die schnauze halten wenn
werbung okay das auch möglich ist leute
wenn ihr der große bund und in der
großstadt fahren und er durch die u-bahn
okay von hier steht gerade über der u
bahn in der u bahn im tunnel hängt
werbung werde dann sprechen dann
sprechen wir auch über der werbung ist
oben drüber und dann müsst ihr auch
unbedingt die chance erhalten in diesem
moment denn ansonsten wenn euch nicht
daran halte habe ich gehört dass bis zum
deutschen gesetzen verankert kontakt
persönlich bei euch vorbei und verbringt
24 stunden alles klar von diesen kleinen
chaotischen video hier findet ihr wie
immer dinge wo er mich abonnieren könnt
und so bricht also franke der wisse
wie's läuft bis nicht mal vielleicht
etwas bevor ich eigentlich class zwei
laster und 8 und genau die momente ich
das hier machen denken immer alle keine
eindeutige beweis gucke ich habe eine
hohe an das ist keine boxershorts die
volkswirtschaftlichen drunter das ist
die boxershorts so fucking badehose und
ich mach videos in badehose und nicht
als klatsche